if you look at the sky
after sunset and you see something very
bright glowing near the horizon and you
say oh my god what's that it's almost
certain to be venus it's one of the
brightest objects in the sky
we call it the evening star or the
morning star because it tends to because
it's close to to the sun in the solar
system it tends to follow the sun or or
precede it in sunrise
so the symbol for venus is actually a
hand mirror
because venus was the roman goddess of
love and beauty and we see this symbol
all over the place not just in astronomy
because it's culturally it's now our
symbol for woman or for
femininity
and this is counterbalanced by the
symbol for mars which people recognize
as a symbol for for men it's a it's a
circle with a
an arrow coming out of it and that's the
the
um representing the shield and the spear
because mars was the roman god of war
and so these are these symbols that have
come out of astronomy into everyday life
meaning male and female well it's it's
often called our sister planet because
it's right next door to earth it's the
next planet closest to the sun
and it's also almost the same size as
earth
which is interesting and it has an
atmosphere like earth does as well but
it's not a place that you would want to
go on holiday
not at all because that atmosphere
is actually almost entirely carbon
dioxide and so what we see on venus
is actually a runaway greenhouse effect
so that atmosphere is very very good at
trapping the heat from the sun and
keeping it there so venus is incredibly
hot
on the surface of venus
the temperatures are high enough to melt
lead
and with that is incredible atmospheric
pressure
so standing on the surface of venus you
would feel the same amount of pressure
as if you were 800 meters below the
surface of the
sea
above that if that's not enough to put
off your holiday plans
it also the atmosphere rains sulfuric
acid so basically it's not a very
hospitable place to be even though it's
one of the closer planets to us it's
very unlikely that we're probably going
to send
human beings there in the near or even
in the far future
now in an unexplored region of space
mariner was placed on its mercury
intercept course by the gravity of venus
so it's hard for us to see the surface
of venus or it's impossible for us
because it has this really really thick
atmosphere so we've actually we being
humanity
mostly the americans and the former
soviet union have sent a number of
probes to venus all the way back from
the 60s through the 70s
some of those
orbited and used radar to pierce the
clouds and some of them even managed to
land and now this was a very difficult
piece of engineering to accomplish
because the conditions there are so
harsh and in fact the earlier landers
didn't make it very far they were
crushed by the incredible
temperatures pressures or melted by the
temperatures
but some of them did actually make it
down there so we we do actually have
pictures
of the surface of venus
nasa's mariner spacecraft after
traveling four months and 217 million
miles began fulfilling its mission as it
rendezvoused with the planet venus
this year being 2009 is of course the
400th anniversary of galileo taking a
telescope
and
pointing it at the heavens
and one of the things that he observed
which was very very important
was he managed to observe the full
phases of venus
so venus like the moon
undergoes phases from our point of view
because it changes its position relative
to the sun
and in at galileo's time it was still
working under this
idea of the universe that the earth was
at the center
and his observations of venus undergoing
this full spectrum of phases
didn't fit in with that picture at all
and in fact that was one of the greatest
pieces of evidence that they had
that
that system was wrong and that we had to
move our understanding of the universe
away from the earth being the center
towards the sun being the center
so for me that observation of venus
it just goes to show what astronomy does
astronomy makes us change the way
we see ourselves
as part of the larger universe and
simply by taking a telescope and
pointing it at the heavens and seeing
something new that didn't fit we had to
change our entire world view